like
my size
down
so
foreign
so
oh
actually
oh
oh
it's
for planning purposes i just want to let
you know
a few more minutes okay
so
oh
um
okay
well that's fine
all right
[Applause]
so i'm not sorry
oh yes
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
here
uh
okay
foreign
[Music]
yes
yes
but
okay
all right
he's
right
yes
yes
[Music]
okay
okay
okay
yes
you
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
so
so
okay
over there
all right
foreign
so
knuckles
oh
is
hello
is
thank god
[Music]
yes
so
i
a
[Music]
so
wow
foreign
okay okay
thank you
thank you
yeah yeah
um
foreign
yes
okay
uh
nice
so
right
okay
uh
okay
yes
so
they're on their way out
uh i i was here last night
i'm feeling good tested negative again
today you know it's uh
pretty good morning everyone
thank you for coming uh dr sean connelly
position to the president uh this
morning i'd like to start by
uh first sharing that the president and
first family first lady
extremely grateful the enormous
outpouring of support and prayers
that the whole world and country i've
been providing and sharing
i'd like to thank colonel andrew barr
and all the medical and support staff
here at walter reed
for their tireless efforts providing
everything and anything the medical team
the president and i could need this
morning the president is doing very well
behind me are some of the members of uh
the president's medical team
whom i'd like to introduce uh
dr shawn dooley pulmonary critical care
dr brian garibaldi pulmonary critical
care
dr robert browning pulmonary critical
care
dr jason blaylock infectious disease
dr wes campbell infectious disease
dr john hodgson anesthesia
major kurt klein army nurse commander
megan nazworthy
navy nurse lieutenant juliana lavopa
navy nurse lieutenant lieutenant
commander john shea clinical pharmacist
and not present with us our lieutenant
beth carter lieutenant maureen meehan
both navy nurses
and dr jesse show now director of our
executive medicine program
as reported yesterday consultation with
this group
i recommended we bring the president up
to walter reed
as a precautionary measure to provide
state-of-the-art monitoring and any care
that he may need just 72 hours into the
diagnosis now
the first week of covid and a particular
day 7-10 are the most critical
in determining the likely course of this
illness
at this time the team and i are
extremely happy with the progress the
president has made
thursday he had a mild cough and some
nasal congestion and fatigue
all of which are now resolving and
improving at this time i'd like to bring
up dr dooley to discuss some of the
specifics of the president's care
thank you and uh good afternoon i'm dr
sean dooley as dr conley mentioned
i'll start off by uh mentioning what
what an incredible
uh how incredibly proud i am of our
medical team assembled behind me
uh and the honor it's been to care for
the president over these last
24 hours here at walter reed he's
receiving outstanding multi-disciplinary
care
the state of the science for coronavirus
infection
we are monitoring him very closely uh
for any evidence of complications from
either the coronavirus illness or the
therapies that we are prescribing to
make him better we have monitored his
cardiac function
his kidney function his liver function
all of those
are normal and the president this
morning is not on
oxygen not having difficulty breathing
or
walking around uh the white house
medical unit upstairs
he's in exceptionally good spirits and
in fact as we were completing our
multi-disciplinary rounds this morning
uh the quote he left us with was i feel
like i could walk out of here today and
that was a very encouraging
comment from the president moving
forward i'll go ahead and introduce dr
garabali who will talk about some of our
therapeutics
and the plan for plan of care for today
thank you
thank you dr dooley and i'd like to echo
the sentiment from the entire team what
a
honor and a privilege it is to be part
of this multidisciplinary unit to care
for the president
um about 48 hours ago the president
received
a special antibody therapy directed
against the coronavirus and we're
working very closely with the company to
monitor him
in terms of that outcome um yesterday
evening he received his first dose of
ivory rem deserve
and our plan is to continue a five-day
treatment course for rem deserver
and the big plan for today since he's in
such great spirits and doing well is to
encourage him to eat
to drink to stay hydrated to be up out
of bed
and to be working and doing the thing
things that he needs to do
uh to get well um i'll refer dr conway
to any questions
thanks brian it's important the
president's been fever-free for over 24
hours
uh we remain cautiously optimistic
but he's doing great um with that
oh one other note it should be clear
that he's got plenty of work
to get done from the chief of staff
and he's doing it but that if there's a
couple questions
about the president's health uh in the
last couple days
sir can you tell us the president's
oxygen saturation levels
yeah so the the last uh saturation that
we had up walking around he was
about 96 percent receiving notes he has
not received any supplemental options
he's not on oxygen right now that's
right
he's not received any at all he's he's
not needed anybody any uh
this morning today at all that's right
no he's
do you have an estimated date when he
might be discharged
uh well i don't want to put a hard date
on that
um he's doing so well but the
with a known course of the illness day
seven to ten we get really concerned
about the inflammatory phase phase two
um given that we provided some of these
uh
advanced therapy so early in the course
a little bit earlier than most of the
patients we know and follow
um it's hard to tell where he is
on that course and so every day we're
evaluating does he need to be here
what does he need and where is he going
what do you see is the probability that
he will need supplemental oxygen going
forward
i don't want to put a percentage on that
but but right now all indicators
are that uh uh that he'll remain off of
oxygen uh going forward
and in terms of like blood clots
pneumonia bacterial infection what do
you see is the risk on that front
well we know that all of them are risks
associated with this condition
um uh he is receiving all of the
standard of care and beyond uh per
routine you know international coveted
protocols um so
we're monitoring for all of that um but
at the moment there's no
cause for concern you said he was he's
fever-free now what was his fever when
he had one sir
uh i'd rather not give any specific
numbers but he but he did have a fever
uh thursday into friday and since friday
morning
he's had none okay what was the date
in the body i'm sorry on top of the
antibodies
uh so remdezavir works a little bit
differently than the antibodies we're
maximizing
all aspects of his care attacking
this virus you know multi-pronged
approach
as a president i didn't want to hold
anything back
if there was any possibility that it
would add value to his care and
expedite his return um i wanted to take
it
and the team agreed and that's what we
proceeded doctor what was the date of
the president's last
negative test i'm not going to get into
all the testing going
back um but but he and all the staff
routine uh
routinely uh are tested um and so
doctor what is the pbe protocol for uh
president trump receiving visitors and
doctors it's the same as any hospital
has
we have an area that's uh clean that you
you put your equipment on
and then beyond that everybody is fully
gowned up
masks gloves we're protecting ourselves
and him has have you done a screen has
there's been any sign of any lung damage
whatsoever
we are we are following all of that we
do daily ultrasounds we do daily lab
work
the team is tracking all of that has
there been any sign of damage i'm not
going to go into specifics of what the
findings about
one thing has he ever been on
supplemental oxygen
he right now he is not honest i know you
keep saying right now but should we read
into the fact that he had been free
yesterday and today he was not on oxygen
so he has not been on it during this his
covenant treatment
he's he's not on oxygen right now has
hydroxide been considered as a vibrant
treatment option for the president uh we
discussed it he asked about it
uh he's not on it now and doctor what uh
symptoms has he also experienced
difficulty breathing
no no he has not never did a little
cough
he had the fever more than anything he's
felt run down
who is handling contact tracing is that
the white house or cdc
yeah the white house uh uh white house
medical unit in conjunction with uh
you know collaboration with cdc and
local state and health departments are
conducting all contact tracing for cdc
guidelines
when was the positive diagnosis made you
said 72 hours that would prove that
wednesday
yeah uh so thursday afternoon
uh following uh uh following
the news of a closed contact is when we
repeated testing
um and given kind of clinical
indications and a little bit more
concern
and that's when that late that night uh
we got the pcr
confirmation that that he was is there
any clarity on how he became infected
not going to go into that as far as his
care it's irrelevant
or when he became infected yeah we're
not going to go into that uh we're just
tracking his
clinical course and providing the best
care we can will president trump have to
stay at walther need to get
the five-day language for your treatment
um we've discussed that right now
if he needs all five days uh that will
likely be the course
um but again every day we're reviewing
with the team
uh his needs for being here and uh and
as soon as he gets to the point where uh
it's not a requirement
he may still need some care but if we
can provide that downtown
at the house then we will transition at
that point as long as it's
safe and appropriate the team agrees in
addition to his weight
does he have any other risk factors that
make him more at risk for sort of a
severe case
well not particularly i mean he's he's
74
he's male and he is slightly overweight
um other than that he's very healthy
his cholesterol is great his blood
pressure is great it's not on medication
for that
um he's up and active you sell the uh
his activity the days leading up to
long hours and everything else you know
he's able to handle it can you provide
other vitals like heart rate blood
pressure and temperature
um so his his heart rate is in the uh
70s the 80s
his blood pressure has remained where
it's where it's historically been during
our physicals
uh you know 110 to 120 to stop he's
great
it's never budged uh had no concerns
there so why was the decision made to
transfer him here
because he's the president of the united
states and obviously if doctors have
found that the prone position is helpful
for covet has he been in that at all no
we actually
he asked about that he did thursday into
friday
he's been briefed by the task force and
all scientists for months
and he brought that up you know we were
discussing his cough
and at that time his oxygen levels were
okay we didn't feel like we needed to do
it we came up here discussed it with the
team as well
um we consider all options but he has
not needed any of that
why wasn't the first lady admitted as
well uh the first lady's doing great
thanks for asking
she had no indication for
hospitalization
advanced therapy she's convalescing at
home uh
thank you i'm gonna try to pin you down
one more time i know you said there was
no other yeah
yeah yeah he's not on oxygen today
on thursday and he's what's today
saturday
uh no no thursday no thursday no friday
saturday that's fine so that was why we
were
thursday no oxygen none at this moment
yeah and yesterday with the team
uh while we were all here he was not on
oxygen
so has the president actually been
admitted as a patient
to this hospital the president is a
patient
at walter reed national military medical
center is he on any steroids
thank you very much